c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
seraient les bienvenues sur france 24
est la une ce soir l'ukraine qui va
rapatrier ses casques bleus déployés sur
le continent ces soldats sont présents
au mali au sud soudan mais surtout en
république démocratique du congo rdc ils
sont 250 au sein de la monusco la
mission de l'onu dans le pays
nous serons à kinshasa dans ce journal
en guinée 58 partis d'opposition dans
l'ufdg de cellou dalein diallo ont
exprimé leur désaccord sur la durée de
la transition militaire menée par la
junte au pouvoir la correspondance à
conakry dans un instant et à la fin de
ce journal nous vous emmènerons au ranch
de gibier de nazinga au burkina faso
vous verrez que les espèces protégées
qui y vivent sont désormais menacés par
les groupes armés qu'ils braconnent pour
se nourrir ou pour se financer reportage
à suivre
250 casques bleus ukrainien s'apprête à
quitter la république démocratique du
congo kiev a décidé de rapatrier ses
soldats de maintien de la paix pour
renforcer les rangs de son armée et ses
équipements militaires à goma dans le
nord kivu la population comprend cette
décision les précisions de notre
correspondant à kinshasa clément
bonnerot
250 casques bleus ukrainiens sont
déployés dans l'est de la rdc sur un
total de quinze mille militaires pour
l'ensemble de la monusco il s'agit de la
plus grosse mission de paye craignait à
l'étranger ces casques bleus sont
présents au nord kivu et au sud kivu et
en ituri et travaille principalement
dans l'aviation il contribue notamment
avec huit gros hélicoptère qui facilite
le transport des soldats et leur
ravitaillement dans des zones qui sont
parfois extrêmement difficile d'accès à
goma beaucoup d'habitants disent
comprendre la décision de rapatrier les
casques bleus ukrainien le gouvernement
a pris une décision rationnelle ils sont
d'abord militant ukrainien avant d'être
et casques bleus de la monusco et ils se
sont alarmés d'abord pour défendre
l'ukraine mais je voulais aussi profité
pour témoigner ma sympathie au peuple
ukrainien qui entrait de faire preuve
d'un courage extraordinaire ils sont en
train de nous donner nous autres délais
sont des commandes des faillites nation
saison des visuels qui sont en danger en
ukraine et donc nous ne pouvons que
compatir avec bien que chez nous aussi
ça ne va pas il ya toujours eu des
décades des tueries à des gens qui
meurent en cascade il ya des gens qui
meurent en masse et voilà c'est la
situation du pays pour l'instant la date
de départ des casques bleus ukrainien
n'est pas connue des discussions sont en
cours à new york lors d'un briefing à la
presse mercredi le porte parole du
secrétaire général de l'onu stéphane
dujarric a salué le soutien apporté par
l'ukraine à la monusco il a également
indiqué que le contingent ukrainiens
seraient remplacés par des casques bleus
d'un autre état membre afin de continuer
de mener à bien la mission de maintien
de la paix en rdc
on vous en parlait en début de semaine
l'accès à l'essence au nigeria est de
plus en plus compliqué la situation a
empiré depuis le déclenchement de la
guerre en ukraine ce jeudi le fmi a
prévenu que ce conflit allait avoir des
conséquences sur l'augmentation des prix
du carburant et de la nourriture en
afrique shirli sitbon
la pénurie de pétrole les nigérians ils
font face depuis longtemps surtout ces
derniers mois ici les carburants sont
utilisés pour les voitures mais aussi
pour faire fonctionner les générateurs
électriques
sa date is where
we du streak est il faut
maroc
pour le fmi la guerre en ukraine et les
sanctions à l'encontre de la russie et
de ses carburants risque d'empirer la
crise pour la chef du fmi de nombreuses
économies africaines seront vulnérables
avec des prix à la hausse pour les
économistes le nigeria premier
producteur de pétrole en afrique peut
sortir de cette crise
plus tôt
cette semaine le nigeria connaît une
nouvelle étape dans la crise les vols
sont désormais annulée par manque de
carburant
la réaction de bamako après les
accusations de la mauritanie à
l'encontre de ces soldes à nouakchott
les tient pour responsable de la mort
d'une trentaine de ses ressortissants le
gouvernement malien a annoncé mercredi
soir l'ouverture d'une enquête sur ces
assassinats sur son territoire mais
assuré que rien pour l'instant ne
permettait d'accuser des soldats maliens
ce calcul macabre soudan deux nouveaux
manifestants anti putsch ont été tuées
ce jeudi à khartoum les représentants de
l'onu et de l'union africaine estime que
le pays est en grave danger depuis le
coup d'état du 25 octobre dernier
événement qui a exacerbé les violences
et aggraver la crise économique dans le
pays
on part à présent en guinée où les
partis d'opposition ont exprimé leur
désaccord sur la durée de la transition
militaire menée par la junte au pouvoir
dans un communiqué publié ce mercredi 58
partis politiques dans l'ufdg de cellou
dalein diallo dénonce des
dysfonctionnements qui selon selon eux
empêchent une organisation rapide des
élections la correspondance à conakry de
malik diakité
dans cette déclaration ces partis
politiques dénoncent tout d'abord le
manque de dialogue avec les militaires
ils accusent la chanteuse site de
violations répétées de la charte qui
stipule que la durée de la transition
date et robes des terminée autour d'un
dialogue entre toutes les forces vives
de la nation et les militaires le cnt
l'organe consultatif qui joue le rôle de
l'assemblée nationale n'est pas censé
déterminer cette durée contrairement à
ce que prévoient les militaires les
signataires du communiqué soupçonne les
militaires de vouloir se maintenir au
pouvoir nous sommes à six mois depuis la
prise du pouvoir rien année on n'a
aucune visibilité du est sûre la
transition dans notre pays donc ça veut
dire qu'ils veulent tirer en longueur
ça ne peut pas marcher comme ça parce
que les militaires ne sont pas faits
faut diriger un état ici on s'entend pas
si elle pas nadal s'il n'y a pas de
visibilité ne vaut pas le choix
la société reste à faire c'est l'effet
des manifestations de rue nous voulons
pas aller les villages c'est pour cent
demandons à ce que tout le monde
s'implique et pour qu'on puisse se
retrouver autour de la table à signaler
que le rpg arc en ciel le parti du
président dessus alpha condé ne fait pas
partie des signataires de cette
déclaration
au tchad à quatre jours de l'ouverture
des négociations avec les rebelles la
junte au pouvoir a décidé de remplacer
le comité chargé d'amener à la rébellion
à la table des négociations par une un
autre organe de médiation il était
présidé par goût kumi goukouni par don
waddell président du tchad de 79 à 82 le
nouvel organe le comité spécial chargé
de conduire les négociations est composé
désormais de groupe et alliance rebelle
retour à la vie normale au gabon après
deux ans de couvre-feu et de
restrictions sanitaires le pays a levé
ces mesures au grand bonheur des
gabonais qui ont vite retrouvé leurs
habitudes et se sont retrouvés autour
d'un verre pour fêter leurs
retrouvailles en lieu public la
correspondance à libreville 10 mélo bien
c'est
fini le stress des restrictions de
mouvement vive la liberté de plusieurs
soirs les lieux de loisirs tels que les
cafés les bars ont renoué avec leurs
habitudes de grands rassemblements entre
amis autour d'un verre ici à libreville
c'est le soulagement total mais la
nouvelle bien que longtemps attendu et
douché par un sentiment d'amertume car
le coc u19 a occasionné la perte des
milliers d'emplois dans plusieurs
secteurs d'activités tels que le pétrole
qui représente à lui seul plus de 80%
des ressources de l'état écoutez la
réaction de quelques gabonais que nous
avons rencontrés aujourd'hui après
l'annnonce de la levée des mesures
sanitaires l'économie sont bafoués un
obligé de repartir à zéro cette année
chercher des finances d'ailleurs
auparavant jamais promis beaucoup de
choses
apparemment ça a bien commencé mais elle
s'était du mas est bloqué du coup on
s'est sentis délaissés a pâti de cette
mère y avait des difficultés des
difficultés à se déplacer
donc à partir de maintenant tous ceux
qui étaient dans cette situation
embarrassante vont pouvoir les activités
ont peu après le boulot aller avec des
amis en soirée
prendre un jus prennent un verre au
gabon le taux de couverture vaccinale
situe désormais au dessus de 50% avec
plus de 300 décès enregistrés en deux
ans d'épidémie et une moyenne de 15
personnes détectées par jour la
situation épidémiologique en nette
amélioration et justifie donc la levée
des restrictions sanitaires malgré tout
le chef de l'état gabonais invite ses
concitoyens à poursuivre l'effort de
vaccination
avant de se quitter en vous propose une
visite guidée du ranch de gibier de
nazinga situé au burkina faso à 10 km de
la frontière du ghana
cette zone est aujourd'hui menacée par
les groupes armés des djihadistes qui
braconnent pour se nourrir mais aussi
pour financer leur guerre notre
correspondant burkina faso kalidou sy a
suivi une équipe de gardes forestiers
dans cette réserve reportage
à première vue ces hommes en équipements
militaires et armes de pointe pourrait
passer pour des forces de sécurité
burkinabè et pourtant ce matin là cette
unité de soldats s'apprêtent à
patrouiller pour remplir sa mission la
protection des espaces naturels et la
lutte anti braconnage
qui nous informent d'être que l'attaqué
à noter
cette zone c'est le ranch de gibier de
nazinga une immense réserve naturelle de
près de cent mille hectares situé dans
la région centre-sud à 10 km de la
frontière du ghana dans ce joyau vert
les stars se sont peu les éléphants ils
cohabitent avec des milliers d'animaux
parmi lesquels le coc bat le but balle
ou encore le crocodile mais en 2018 une
nouvelle menace a fait son apparition
l'insécurité liée aux groupes armés ils
braquent comme pour se nourrir et
financer leurs activités ces éco gardes
accompagné de forestiers exerce donc une
fonction cruciale pour la protection de
la faune et des massifs forestiers
ont vaqué
deux espèces qui sont nazes à amman - de
la slovène et malgré une nette
amélioration depuis deux ans
l'insécurité a tout de même eu un impact
néfaste sur le tourisme la fréquentation
a chuté de 6000 à seulement dix
visiteurs par an mais grâce au travail
de benjamin bassono qui avec son ong
accompagne les avis policiers pour la
conservation et la sécurisation du parc
la zone est aujourd'hui plus sûre en
2019 a eu quelques velléités
d'occupation mais tout de suite avec
l'appui de l'union européenne qui a mis
beaucoup de moyens à la disposition des
ong à gênes ça nous a permis d'éviter
l'installation de l'insécurité d'un
homme seul aujourd'hui nous disons dieu
merci nous sommes à l'abri de ces genres
d'activités
terroristes ici nous sommes totalement
en sécurité nos visiteurs sont
accompagnés ce que les importer pendant
leur séjour une sécurité retrouver un
argument essentiel pour relancer le
tourisme de la réserve animalière de
nazinga qui abrite l'une des plus grande
population d'éléphants de savane
d'afrique de l'ouest
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique merci aux équipes en régie
merci à notre chef d'édition célia
karacena et merci à vous de nous suivre
chaque soir
[Musique]